après tim burton et christopher nolan
c'est au tour de matt reeves de proposer
sa vision du batman l'homme
chauve-souris alias bruce wayne avec
dans le rôle titre robert pattinson
alors commence en partie du mythe mon
cher sinon c'était toute la question on
était en droit de se poser qu'on se pose
à chaque nouvelle incarnation du
personnage parce que batman fait partie
on va dire des plus anciens des plus ces
minots super héros américains il existe
depuis les années 30 dont qu'il a
connues quantité d'itérations
différentes quantités de vision
particulière aussi parce que c'est un
personnage de par le fait qu'il est
strictement humain en gros c'est un
milliardaire qui va taper des pauvres
pardon des méchants et bien tout
simplement ça offre une quantité
d'interprétations possibles énorme et
donc matt reeves est un excellent choix
parce qu'il s'est dit mais moi je vais
revenir à ce qui est l'adn de ce
personnage c'est que c'est un détective
ça n'est pas forcément comme dans les
dernières incarnations qu'on a pu voir
avec kristen bell d'un côté ou avec ben
affleck de l'autre un espèce de boulet
de démolition humain qui viendraient
nécessairement se battre ou qui serait
en premier lieu un combattant c'est un
enquêteur c'est quelqu'un qui investigue
et donc matt reeves est un très bon
choix parce que c'est non seulement un
très fin technicien mais on peut aussi
le voir c'est un énorme cinéphiles alors
on a beaucoup dit au moment de la
promotion de ce film sans doute pour
essayer de prendre l'aspiration de la
trilogie nolan que c'était un batman
réaliste c'est sans doute un batman
sombre je ne pense pas que ce soit un
batman réaliste parce que justement son
monde son univers est un pur agglomérat
est un patchwork de références
cinéphiliques qui le rendent assez
passionnant et on valoir dans une
séquence où il discute avec le fameux
commissaire gordon tout simplement ils
essayent de sortir de ce d'un
commissariat qui remplit de pourri et
lui est bien embêté parce que tout le
monde aimerait le démasquer il n'ya que
gordon qui joue avec lui ils vont donc
mine de s'entretenir avant que gordon
levitt passe par derrière et tape mois
dessus et regarder alors là l'image est
un peu sombre mais ce qu'on ne voit
passer que ce masque la partie sur le nu
ça nous rappelle ça nous rappelle le
pansement sur le nez de nicholson dans
chinatown la cette mise en scène on est
quasiment dans angel heart derrière eux
hier on l'a vu dans le tout premier plan
qui ouvrait cette séquence une quantité
de petites enchevêtrement de grille et
cette lumière rejoignant derrière on est
aux portes de l'enfer et la regarder en
fait ce commissariat sur gardien de
plein emploi on est incapable de dire
exposées dans les années 50 ce qu'on est
dans des cellules anti émeutes des
années 90 est-ce qu'on est au contraire
chez lui met dans les seventies c'est
impossible à dire parce que quasiment à
chaque plan est un moment de cinéma et
la regarde et on passe quasiment chez
vertigo ce grand plan d escalier en
colimaçon
mais on le travaille autrement on va à
l'intérieur parce que c'est un film qui
est là pour explorer tous l'impensé tout
l'univers de batman et là vous voyez
avec cette image qui avec ses images
fixes qui défilent également un certain
cinéma noir mais aussi un cinéma
gothique est tout simplement c'est un
des grands plaisirs de ce film justement
c'est d'avoir un super héros à regarder
un film à admirer qu'ils pensent ce
cadre et qui pense toujours en termes de
cinéma alors il ya un super héros
admirés mais il ya aussi une super
héroïne et je vois vous n'avez pas été
insensible au charme de catwoman oui
charme donc de zoë kravitz qui joue
catwoman avec qui vont former on va dire
un duo radio ils chassent un petit peu
là l'autre face il ya une espèce de jeu
d'amour de désir qui arrêtent pas sans
cesse de de s'effectuer je vous montrais
un extrait et je vais vous montrer en
fait moi ce qui m'a plu dans ce film
c'est le côté un peu old school de ce
batman c'est à dire on se souvient on va
dire de tous les films de super-héros
actuellement qui sont encore en train de
nous nous d'arriver de partout avec des
effets numériques et vous allez voir
quand fait matrix est un artisan
hollywoodien est un artisan qui revient
on va dire à quelque chose d'assez
simple simple c'est à dire regardez
comment elle effectue un cambriolage eh
ben elle utilise des objets solides on
n'est pas en train de percer les choses
avec des effets numériques complètement
dingue vous avez 11 plans exactement
pour montrer la minutie de son de son
acte de son cambriolage et puis soudain
en 12ème plan est bien quand elle louvre
alain au moment même où elle ouvre elle
entend la voix de bachmann elle se
retourne
vous allez regardez regardez ce plan est
assez long c'est à dire que soudain
patrick nous permet un tout petit peu de
jouer on va dire des corps en train
d'effectuer une chorégraphie c'est à
dire on n'est pas simplement dans un
montage frénétique où on arriverait
absolument pas à suivre la scène
d'action est évidemment cette bagarre
nom n'est pas qu'une c'est aussi une
chorégraphie
amoureuse qui se dessine à ce moment là
et évidemment et ben non c'était lui le
voleur il était venu pour lui piquer son
pas son passeport et moi c'est quelque
chose qui m'a qui m'a beaucoup plu simon
a parlé beaucoup des références
cinéphiliques qui égrène tout le film on
pense évidemment je pense qu'on va en
parler à david fincher en particulier
assez bonne à ces puzzles et j'ai eu
l'impression pendant 1h30 2h en tout cas
de voir une sorte de grand film d'action
un peu à l'ancienne qui est je veux dire
qu'ils n'arrêtent ça n'arrive pas ça
n'arrête parler dans le film noir il ya
de l'action les scènes d'actions n'ont
pas l'air d'être justement filmé sous
tous les angles on s'intéresse pour une
fois des scènes d'action dans un film
dans un film de ce type et d'ailleurs
elle culmine à mon avis dans une des
plus des poursuites en bagnoles les plus
excitantes que j'ai vu au cinéma depuis
très très longues années avec le
pingouin et pour ma part le film aurait
pu s'arrêter là alors que frédéric a
cité seven c'est vrai qu'on pense bien
sûr aux films noirs mais on pense
beaucoup à david fincher on pense à
fincher oppose à seven et aussi pour
tout regarder je vous ai fait un petit
slides avec avec charles besson réalise
de bronzo toute l'équipe du cercle on se
met encore maudit tiens est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas montrer ça regardez vous
veillez à droite vous reconnaissez
morgan freeman et brad pitt dans seven
et ben c'est vraiment ça c'est à dire
que jusque dans l'éclairage moi ce qui
m'intéressait aussi dans seven c'est
l'éclairage de darius khondji avec ce
côté c'est noir qui sont pros fait d'un
manoir et puis ce côté il pleut tout le
temps on est dans une espèce de de
marasme et on retrouve complètement ça
dans le film de matt reeves et à gauche
alors vous allez me dire je reconnais
pas cette séquence de ces votes parce
qu'elle n'est pas dans ses veines c'est
une séquence de chaud vous savez et on
retrouve aussi ce côté parce que avec
seven on a le côté enquêteurs et et
essayer de retrouver les énigmes le
criminel dans le dans le batman laisse
des énigmes à batman mais il ya aussi
des mécaniques comme dans soho c'est à
dire que les victimes sont piégés et en
quelque sorte pour se voir mourir c'est
à dire que elles sont dans des dents
littéralement dans des espèces de cages
de trucs qui vont les étouffer et elles
savent qu'au premier geste elles seront
elles seront écrabouillé il ya et il ya
cette dimension proprement horrifique
qui fait que l'on voit sa mort il ya
quelque chose de plus horrible que si on
vous tuer comme ça quand tu dis c'est
pas réaliste je comprends très bien ce
que tu veux dire et on est d'accord
qu'on n'est pas dans un univers réaliste
bcc réaliste par rapport à un univers
peut-être de super héros c'est à dire
qu'il ya une manière par exemple de
désigner catwoman on la voit avec un
chat on l'a ou avec son masque et puis
on va en rester là après va vivre sa vie
de 2,82 vers qu'il ya tout un présupposé
qu'on a des super héros ils sont pas là
tout en cap et ans et en moule et
tout ça et en collant pour pour faire la
parade et c'est en cela que c'est plus
réaliste mais c'est réaliste comme un
film noir est ce que est ce que seven
est ce que ce sont des bus est ce que le
silence des agneaux sont des films
réalistes à force de jouer comme ça ce
côté très sombre on est dans un univers
de films noirs et c'est ça que je trouve
très passionnant il ya une ambition de
cinéma comme ça où on va pouvoir tisser
des intrigues complexes marie le risque
est très intéressant et c'est pour
rebondir sur ce que tu dis sur quatre
roues man et la stylisation par exemple
de son masque de son costume en fait je
trouve que le film est très heureusement
des comic book is et c'est à dire que le
pingouin qui est un gangster à balafre a
pas besoin de marcher comme un pingouin
catwoman n'a pas de queue en latex effet
pas griller toutes les deux minutes tout
ce qu'ils n'avaient absolument lacets
hérité depuis mille ans j'ai trop je te
rejoins sur le fait que les bagarres
sont vraiment bien d'abord y en a pas
tant que ça ensuite on les voit on voit
ce qui se passe on sent les coups et moi
en tant que présidente honoraire du du
club des gens qui ont ras-le-bol de voir
voler des mecs sur fond vert en collant
j'ai tout à coup ce réalisme là c'est ça
c'est du vrai décor c'est une ville qui
ressemble à une ville alors c'est
peut-être pas aujourd'hui c'est
peut-être mais ça c'est du réalisme
c'est de la chair c'est du nil et les
jaunes organique et on rejoint là dessus
joker et je trouve que le film est
malgré tout
moins neuneu que ne l'était joker pour
faire pour faire court et et le fait de
le rejoindre sur la fin avec les gens
qui sont transformés en riddler et c'est
dans une presque une sorte d' attaque du
capitole
fait en tout cas malgré tout une sorte
de peinture de l'america c'est
intéressant je sens emilie quand même
moins moins enthousiaste ne vous mariez
ce qui se passe c'est que je suis encore
en train de me demander ce que j'ai
pensé du film il ya vraiment un truc qui
m'a énormément troublé dans ce batman
qui est très long donc qui est vraiment
outre au noir c'est vraiment une toile
outrenoir moi ce que j'aime bien c'est
le côté ultra subjectif de ce batman et
le fait qu'on est dans un blockbuster
psychanalytique j'allais dire quasiment
fait c'est totalement psychanalytique et
qu'on est dans la noirceur de batman et
cette espèce de crise existentielle de
dépression qu'on va traverser avec lui
je trouve qu'on la vit presque comme une
expérience physique et ça ça m'intéresse
énormément
ce qui me dérange peut-être un peu
davantage le sentiment que en réaction
peut-être au marvel qui sont dans une
sur l'exubérance
une espèce d'excentricité de moyens de
débauche de moyens j'ai l'impression
qu'il ya une tendance inverse qui
devient tout aussi caricaturale une
certaine manière de dc comics voilà de
vouloir être dans la dépression la sueur
des pressions et donc est ce qu'on peut
est-ce que ce style de blockbusters
dépressif chic j'ai envie de dire
presque devient pas un peu trop
mimétique et nolan a été un petit
président allemand le pape allemand dont
il a l'impression qu'il a quand même
fabriqué au collège les choses à doloow
grave et je suis ravi mais le colonel
nolan soit un créateur c'est pas un
problème après c'est qu'elle est la
descendance de ce créateur de ses
limites j'ai l'impression qu'il ya ce
côté vraiment fait que moi je suis très
solennelle qu'il faut néanmoins ou
combat pour toi pour blake des blocs bel
et bien sûr mais on ne demande pas on ne
demande pas aux films de nous faire rire
il est pas là pour ça ce qui est
peut-être un petit peu dommage vous
évoquez les images très très forte qui à
la fin parce qu'il ya des images
politique à la fin gotham city et quand
même clairement montré et film est
exactement comme la nouvelle orléans au
moment de katrina ce qui veut dire quand
même pas mal de choses
très intéressant et là ça arrive très
tard dans un film on est très long et
qui à un moment c'est un peu perdu en
nous disant non seulement je regarde je
ressemble à un grand film noir mais je
vais vous faire une grande enquête là où
son enquête c'est quand même un petit
peu désuni l'escaut sous tranxène le
sait que le passage de passage mais le
passage au troisième acte est un peu
laborieux parce qu on a été tellement
pris dans cette enquête tellement pris
dans ce film d'action qui vraiment avec
des séquences d'action comme ça fait
longtemps que j'en avais pas vus et à ce
moment là le film doit devenir un peu
explicative et là tu retournes à des
champs contrechamps tu retournes que les
gens saisissent cet argument pour dire
on va peut-être pas y aller parce que ça
fait 3 heures c'est un film qu'il faut
prendre en bloc c'est à dire que c'est
quand même un truc qui vous arrive sur
le paletot et on n'a pas ça toutes les
semaines et y'a quand même il ya quand
même une approche parce que là vous
apportez des images des années 90 je
demanderais aussi pu faire des slides
avec les années 70 mais des désaccords
sur elle est très troublant quand on a
l'impression qu'on est chez coppola donc
mais ce qu'il faut comprendre ce qu'il
faut toujours revenir à des références
ciné c'est une randonnée gourmande a
créé quelque chose le fil invente
quelque chose seulement pour moi une
question le film à une libido et sait
pas si souvent dans les blockbusters